- When we get pulled over in the Batcars,
luckily a lot of the police officers
just want their picture taken with it.
Yes sir, you can.
Please do.
We created the Batcar for the
Michael Keaton Batman movie,
the Mystery Machine from Scooby-Doo,
everything from Herbie the Love Bug
to the Landspeeder from Star Wars.
We create a lot of wild
rides out of some junk.
(lighthearted music)
In the past two or three years,
we've created 15, 16 iconic movie cars.
I had a real job at one
time at a major airline.
We initially started out
refurbishing old cars.
We decided we were gonna
start making some iconic cars
that you could actually
get in and out of it,
drive it, kids can climb
on it and look at it.
Typical builds can be anywhere from
as little as two weeks,
to as much as three years.
The Speed Racer Mach 5
sitting here beside us
started off as a 94 Corvette.
Hopefully here in about 30
days it'll be finished up,
have a great big honking
M on the hood of it,
and it'll look awesome.
There's a tremendous
amount of trial and error.
A lot of these cars have a
lot of fiberglass on 'em.
It's a labor of love to come out
and just continue putting down
layers and layers of fiberglass.
You can't go to O'Riley's
or Advanced Auto Parts
and ask 'em for a part for a Batcar.
(upbeat music)
Our Eleanor from Gone in
60 Seconds car up front
is absolutely as screen-
accurate as we can get it.
From the stainless aluminum
interior to the seats
to the shifter, the go
baby switch in the center.
And we drive Eleanor just like
it's supposed to be driven.
That's why it was built.
(engine revving)
(tires screeching)
Everything we have we take out and drive.
Every single piece.
We take it all to the local
stores, we'll go to McDonald's.
What better thing to get
groceries in than the Batcar?